she's already thinking about she's
already giving you conditions to keep
the relationship if a woman truly loves
you you sit there and say look i've been
around the world i'm about it i know
things you don't know signing that piece
of paper is bad for me it's also bad for
you it's bad for business
okay but i don't know you love me okay
so
oh man he's so polite sometimes isn't he
um he's right about one thing i will say
do not give a man conditions
that never work if you have to give a
man conditions like marry me or else he
doesn't want to marry you
stop doing it just you can decide
you're with a guy for x amount of time
you can decide you're ready to get
married you're tired of being you feel
strung along you can have that
conversation and say listen i do you
want to like are you interested to get
married
they say no i'm not ready or i'm not
interested you then have the power to
say well i'm not going to sit here
anymore i'm going to go find somebody
because this is what i want for my life
i want kids i want direction this is
where i'm at now if it's not going to be
with you end of story but you don't try
to make them feel bullied into it or
pushed into it because then you're going
to wind up with a man who didn't want to
marry you didn't feel comfortable with
it and now feels like he does have a
ball and chain like he's trapped
you don't want that it's not good for
him it's not good for you you'd be much
happier with someone that felt
ready and wanted to make that decision
of their own volition because they
wanted to genuinely marry you that is
where a happy union starts you want it
he wants it you both want it not one
person feels pressured to do it so
andrew's right about that
um
the whole i'm worldly it's just he he is
but you know he's been around he's got a
lot of experience but this whole
onworldly and you're a simpleton act
doesn't work for me i know he's got got
his act going on and all that that's not
going to work for most women either
but what he says about signing that
piece of paper
is being bad for men and women so we
know that it's not we just spent a whole
show talking to you about the
extraordinary benefits that marriage can
have
we went through benefits for men again
physically
mentally financially sexually
the the deep multifaceted benefits for
men when it comes to marriage
again though it seems like these guys
always it's like they're imagining worst
case scenario all the time
marriage you say the word marriage and
they immediately think of somebody who's
using them who's trying to take their
money
who's going to stay married and then
divorce them
in a few years and walk away with half
the cash
again
that's that's just if you want to play
that game
you're going to be very unhappy you're
going to be alone and you're going to be
ignoring a whole lot of women that
aren't shitty
don't want to do that to you and would
really like a partner
okay now andrew tate may not want that
maybe he doesn't want a partner
maybe he doesn't want any of those
things but maybe you do
and you're listening to that and you're
thinking marriage is bad for me no the
right marriage can be
really really really good for you the
right marriage
don't jump into it you know like we said
but don't dismiss it on day one
that's just this is not
you guys got to really think about the
stats think about your own life think
about what you want
you may not want his life
maybe you do maybe you want to have a
mane and then have a but maybe you do
think about that
but again think about the stats on
happiness because a lot of those guys
that are single they're not happy
they're stressed out they're lonely
they're not happy
we got the stats on that we shared them
with you earlier also you can't run your
marriage like a business
he said it's like business it's not not
everything can be run like a business
and a marriage are two very different
things
a good business is managed based on
profit
right that's why i always say the
government you can't compare a
government institution to a business too
because the government doesn't have to
make money right businesses
good business practices are all centered
around who you hire
what your setup looks like you want to
make money you want to make profit a
marriage just it isn't just about profit
it's not just about finances
okay it's about give and take it's about
partnership it's about caring about
someone it's about having somebody be
there for you when you need them and you
be there for them when they need you
if it's just a business
if you're gonna look at marriage just as
a business then yeah don't bother
don't bother
get a business partner get a roommate
get a roommate with a lot of money so
you can get a nice pad end of story
but think about what happens in a world
where everybody started to look at the
equation like that and saw marriage as
business
what would it look like
not too appealing
not too appealing think about kids where
do they even a marriage is like a
business and then you bring kids into
the world is that is that the picture is
that the greeting card you want
everybody looked at a greeting card when
they were young and said oh man that
looks so peaceful to me
you know a family a dog running around
i think that makes a lot of people's
endorphins run that is a marriage that's
not set up like a business it's set up
like partnership know the difference
know what you want and stop listening to
advice that's not going to take you down
a path to your own happiness if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]